cs go skins are a beautiful thing but
the gambling market surrounding them
is not so pretty for years now the world
of csgo skin gambling and trading
has been a murky one if you're not
careful you can get ripped off
really easily so to break it down and
understand what the hell is going on
we spoke to two people who know these
worlds inside
and out right guys you know the deal
scroll down and hit that sub button
we are so close to hitting 2 million
subs and we need your help to get there
and while you're at it hit that
notification bell so you never miss a
new video ever again
so if you've ever watched or played a
modicum of counter-strike
you'll understand when i say that csgo
skins
are a tantalizing thing to own from the
common bloodsport to the ultra rare
dragon lore
having a robust inventory of cs go skins
is a way of life just ask our resident
skin d-gen
dimitri alright so as the score esports
is one and only cosmetic degenerate
i am here to walk you through the only
thing in this operation that
actually matters i'm talking of course
about
schemes but the ways in which you buy
sell
trade and even gamble with these skins
is a confusing and often dangerous
combination of
systems and to help break this down we
talked with cs go streamer mo
on what he sees as the biggest issue
with cs go skin gambling
the main issue that's always haunted the
cs go
gambling scene is the underage gambling
problem
and the underage gambling problem is
simply put
p there's the casinos didn't really have
any system to stop underage kids from
throwing their skins on there it's not
easy to solve because there's no 100
foolproof way to do it nowadays the
sites that are still around
all of them have like these licenses out
of a foreign country
and they seem to be a lot more aware now
the cleanest and most
above board way to acquire a skin in cs
go
is through in-client case openings you
buy a key from steam aka daddy valve and
then
use that to open up one of those shiny
yellow boxes
that give you a tiny chance of winning
an incredibly cool and expensive skin
the downside of opening cases this way
is that you almost
never get an incredibly rare skin
usually it's some [ __ ] green nonsense
for the auto shoddy that you never
use the upside is that you always get
something you don't have to worry about
getting ripped off by some [ __ ]
teenager living in delaware now once you
leave the sanctity of the cs go game
client
things get a little murkier for the
purposes of this video we aren't going
to be focusing on cs go skin
trading that much but here's how it
basically works
there are a ton of different third-party
websites some shadier than
others that allow people to sell or
trade
their skins for a profit think of it
like trading sneakers or magic the
gathering cards
and ever since china got into the skins
game in april of 2020
cs go skins have skyrocketed in price
and rarity
and are now treated like legitimate
investments again
just ask dimitri we made a whole video
talking about csgo skin trading a while
back
the world of buying selling and unboxing
cs go skins
is often an exciting place a world where
having a few stickers on your ak can
mean a 10
000 difference when it comes time to
sell now if you want to buy a skin from
one of these sites
you should 100 percent do your homework
because you can get ripped off otherwise
there's just a lot of dudes out there
who will offer you 500 bucks or less
for your 2 000 knife if you're not
careful
you should compare prices from a bunch
of different sites and if you have
somebody that you can go to who knows a
lot about this process
like our boy zipple you should
definitely talk to them as well
or hell just watch zipplestream where he
does a lot of this
already how much should i add to upgrade
float
that's a good question that one is so
beat up though
i would personally probably pay like
1500 rmb to upgrade
i don't know if that makes sense now
skin gambling is similar to skin
trading in the sense that both these
worlds are unforgiving and dangerous
if you're not careful peaking in
popularity around 2016
most cs go skin gambling sites worked
like this
people wanting to place bets would
convert their skins into the currency
that the site chooses to use
take cs go diamonds for example players
wanting to bet with that website
would convert their skins into diamonds
and then bet those diamonds on different
things
and people bet on a bunch of different
stuff there was your coin flips
your wheel of fortune style spin boards
games of
dice and other casino games that relied
on converted skin
currency if you won you got your skins
back plus the skins in the pot
if you lost you get the point now i also
talked to monarch who owns the skin
gambling site csgo empire
he moved over from roomscape back in
2016 once he realized there was money to
make
i always had this thing in the back of
my mind that someday there may be a
game with an economy even bigger than
landscape and
then i would tap it and actually well
that was a you know
when i when i heard about cs go lounge
and i i saw
like how big the skin economy was then
that was i thought
that's the that's like my calling so i
i went for it over the years monarch
says that he's also
spent time calling out some of these
shadier websites who've allegedly ripped
off
their users by doing things like rigging
the odds
or not paying out winners and he says
because of who he's called
out he's been doxxed harassed and he's
even received death threats
it became like a habit that when people
see something suspicious in the in the
scene
they they come to me they they ping me
on twitter and
sometimes if i see something like really
stuff going on then i
then i start yelling about it and
it's been working very well we have
managed to bring a lot of like
regulation to the to the scene you can
see that
the shady operators they are kind of
like
walking on eggshells an important part
of the identity of skin gambling is its
weird legality
see broadly speaking u.s gambling laws
don't cover the sale of virtual goods in
esports although a lot of people have
argued that those same laws could be
modified
so while a lot of these websites that
operate in europe or other countries
with looser gambling laws can't
technically cater to u.s customers it's
the internet so
you know it happens anyway now there
have been a
number of high-profile skin gambling
controversies over the years
arguably the biggest of which involves a
website called csgolotto.com
popular youtuber trevor martin who
heavily promoted csgolotto.com
on his channel was also found to be the
owner of that same website
and needless to say people were [ __ ]
pissed when they found out
t martin and pro syndicate didn't
single-handedly tank it this was a
massive
unregulated gambling industry that
people are going to notice eventually
but their dumb scam is why people
noticed it when they did
another infamous case actually involves
mo who landed in hot water that same
year
after the owner of csgodiamonds.com
gave him the odds and percentages of
winning beforehand
essentially rigging his chances of
winning in his
favor it was a hotly debated topic at
the time
mo talked about it on stream extensively
and he says that he's
grown from that experience ever since
then
my biggest takeaway uh after the diamond
situation was
to just first and foremost uh
not to make stupid decisions like that
and and go with the flow even though
it was something that was brought to me
by them i should have
i should have said no and just um held
my ground on hey just give me a refill
it's not a big deal
now the money generated from these skin
gambling websites
isn't chump change because depending on
the report you read
from 2016 onwards the cs go skins
market was worth anywhere between two
and
five billion dollars these two
controversies and others like them
caused a ton
of government scrutiny over the legality
of these skin gambling sites
a class action lawsuit was filed and
valve had to send out cease and desist
letters
demanding these websites stop operating
okay
so it would be disingenuous of me if i
did not take a second to talk about the
connection between
monarch and mo beginning around 2016
these two started working together with
mo
taking on cs go empire monarch's
gambling site at the time
as a sponsor for his youtube channel it
might seem strange
now since cs go skin gambling sites as
youtube's sponsors have diminished over
the years
but at the time this was completely
normal but by 2018
mo and monarch's business relationship
started to fall apart
and they had a pretty public falling out
the feud reignited again recently when
monarch called out rolebit.com
another skin gambling website that mo
was allegedly sponsored by
monarch says that he tried to point out
to moe that the guy that was
running rolebit.com was the same guy who
owned and operated cs go diamonds back
in the day
the website that got mo in a bunch of
hot water i just
posted an observation and they're like
hey mo
you are being sponsored by this guy and
considering that
what happens with csgo diamonds it is
very absurd that you are now sponsored
by the same guy again
that was still quite mind-blowing he
went like crazy
because of that they argued back and
forth on twitter for a while and then
monarch released this long
google document accusing mo of doxing
him amongst other allegations
all of which mo says is just delusional
now in talking to mo about the current
state of csgo skin gambling
he says that all of the heat has moved
from straight skin
betting to case openings on third party
websites
remember how i told you that the most
above board way of getting a skin in cs
go was opening cases in the in-game
client
well now third-party websites are doing
a similar thing offering different
themed cases for you to purchase and
open
but instead of buying a key you just buy
the case from the website outright while
these websites still do big business
there's still a lot of legal concerns
around case openings as
gambling when viewed through the lens of
loot boxes
not to mention the fact that if you buy
a case from one of these third-party
websites
how do you know the odds of which they
give you to get some sick
skin are actually accurate or even true
and if you didn't know loot boxes have
spent a tremendous amount of time in
court over the last few years
with companies like electronic arts
facing three class action lawsuits
over the implementation of loot boxes in
its games we've covered the loot box
situation on this very show
right now everyone's favorite developer
electronic arts is facing
three class action lawsuits with
hundreds of people involved
why well the lawsuits say that ea's
popular sports games
create an endless cycle of gambling
designed to get you to spend more
and more and more money the lawsuit also
says that ea isn't just hiding this fact
they've allegedly been lying about it
for years
now mo said that really these case
opening sites are just a way to create a
layer of separation
or to hide if you will the gambling
that's still going on here
see most case opening sites market
themselves as an innocent way to buy
cases and hopefully get a cool skin but
if you're dropping two grand on a case
that only gives you a 50
chance of winning that cool skin isn't
that
just still gambling as loot boxes and by
extension these case openings become
more and more
regulated mo sees these sites adopting
cryptocurrencies as the future of their
business
you know i don't know which
cryptocurrency it will be
but maybe something that isn't created
yet maybe something that's
already out there but i think more and
more games and cryptocurrency set up
start blurring the lines between like
in-game currency and and real-life
currency because you're gonna start
seeing
it super easy to switch between as for
mo versus the monarch beef
mo says he seriously just wants it to be
left alone
while monarch says he's going to
continue calling out these shadier
websites
so what do you guys think how do you
feel about these case opening sites and
cs go skin gambling as a whole
what do you think about this moe versus
monarch beef let me know in the comments
below
you don't have to worry about getting
ripped off by some [ __ ] teenager
that lives in delaware
all right i feel bad for people who live
in delaware it's probably a beautiful
state but it's also one of those like
flyover states that just gets [ __ ] on by
everybody who lives on the coast
you know like i don't what the [ __ ] is
wrong with delaware
why am i [ __ ] on delaware but why am
i [ __ ] on delaware
why am i talking about delaware